let's just start with aps what can you
tell me about an
arithmetic progression there's an a and
d
there's an a and d okay so these premium
rules they stand for some stuff right
what do they stand for
okay so if we have an a first term
that's good and
d difference a common difference is an
even better way to say it
common difference
okay good we'll come to the n term in a
second let's just make sure we
understand this
you start somewhere right you start at
some number and then to go to each
subsequent number
you add on or you subtract something
right and it's the same every time right
so we could say
uh you know 1 4 7 10
13 right i'm gonna start at one if i add
three
every time maybe i'll even write down
those numbers right one
four seven ten so on right so this is an
arithmetic
progression now we might wanna know i
think was tavar who said what the nth
term is like i i don't want to have to
count up to like the 11th
or or 100th term i want to be able to go
there directly so we would say
t for term the nth term we have a
formula actually for going there
directly yeah go ahead tomorrow a
bracket n
minus one okay okay a plus n minus one
times d fantastic okay very good so the
whole idea here is
if you want to know say the first term
you just have a
plus no lots of the difference so 1 take
away 1
times the difference right but then if
you're like i want the 100th term you'll
start with that first term still and
then you add 99 lots
of the common difference because you had
to go along 99 steps
okay so that's the nth term and there's
another formula to do with n but it's
not a terms in remember
think this is series and sequences
remember
okay um have a think have a think if you
had a bunch of these
you added them up right that's what we
call a
that's a series right so this is a
sequence but if i were to say 1 plus 4
plus 7 plus 10 that's an s for
series or sum right ah okay so what we
did was you remember this trick right we
take this sequence here and we kind of
double it and we can match up your first
and last one
your second and your second last third
and your third last so we do get n
on two right because we take all of them
we pair them up
and then what do we multiply by hmm
there's some um there's some big
brackets in here
plus n minus one d
okay let's have a think about that for a
second what's going on in there um
inside here there's two things put
together
right and i just mentioned them your
first term which we know is a
and you've got your last term well just
you can see your last term which we
already know is this
right so if you have your first term a
and your last term
this when you add them together you get
do you see what you get
in the brackets there in fact i might
even write that down
that's the first and last term
you add them up and every other pairing
as you go in towards the middle will add
up to the
same thing so we divide by two because
we've got we've got a pair they're all
doubled up okay is there anything else
you know
about aps um
you can use simultaneous equations
we'll use simultaneous equations if
we're working out like oh you know
one of these but one of these but not
the rest of it okay
i want you to think i gave you an ap
before what if i gave you a sequence and
you didn't know whether it was an ap
how would you be able to like determine
whether it was or wasn't
what would you do i think
if i gave you well let's just have a
look at this one right i mean i told you
it is but how would you prove to someone
this is definitely an ap just not just
look at the numbers yes right that's
one of those numbers
or you would put a the first two so one
as
one is just a equals one okay
okay so we need to have a look at these
two terms here right to find the
difference
so i guess using the language we've just
developed we'd have to say four minus
one is the second term
take away the first term right and if
this really is an ap
then every time i do that difference it
should be
common right so that should be equal to
for instance
term three take away term two or any of
the other ones right
but this we usually only get three terms
that establishes the sequence
and then we just see if the pattern fits
okay so this is how we verify
that you have an ap okay let's think
about if we can do all this in parallel
for a gp we still start with an a first
term so i'll write that down but we
don't have a common
difference anymore what do we have it's
a common
hmm do we remember what gps are bless
you have a think
we're not we're not adding stuff what's
the other operation we could use
i mean a common difference could also be
subtracting so this could be adding and
subtracting
right it's not plus it's not minus it's
going to be
multiplication right so we call this r
for a common
ratio does that ring a bell
i promise you have even if the memory is
not there um so
if we've got the first time you start
with something and you multiply over and
over and over again
um can someone else give me just make up
a geometric progression
let's start at a different number let's
start at say three
see six okay so it looks like the ratio
here is i
am doubling yeah so what should the next
one be
12. and then if i wanted to keep going
not that i need to but it'd be
24 next and then so on okay
so let's keep on using this same
knowledge with delve here what's the nth
term i'm not going to be like adding
stuff on like in an
ap i'm multiplying right so if i start
with the first term
then what do i do to get to the nth term
along
so i'm going to i'm definitely gonna
multiply by the common ratio but
how many times will i multiply by the
common ratio
minus one n minus one just like here
right you can have a thing just have a
look at an example here this
is term four right term four
you start at the first term you multiply
once
and then twice and then a third time and
then you're on term four
so this is four minus one would give you
r to the power of three
okay what about the sum this one's a bit
trickier
and i'll give you a tip it's a fraction
does that ring any bells it's on it's on
the reference g so if you cannot
remember
right you at least can sort of lean on
that but i wonder if anyone does
i'll give you a start it starts with a
can you take it
i'm totally not reading anything off my
page 1 minus
r to the n and that means on the
denominator can anyone finish it off
there's going to be a one minus r um
this is not the only way we can write
this
by the way another way of writing
the a sum times
um i'm just gonna i'm just gonna write
it you can read yourself
that's fine okay okay so we've got these
two different ways to write the
sum of the first n terms of a gp uh why
do we have two
like we don't have two for this one why
do we have two different forms for it
what's
they both will give you the same answer
every single one why do we why do we
have two
um what was our um what was that oh yeah
no
yeah we're trying to avoid negatives we
we hate negatives which is very
discriminatory but they just
are a place for errors to come up so
let's have a think about the common
ratio in this example right what was the
common ratio again
it was 2. so if i popped r equals 2 into
this one
right i promise we get the right answer
for either of these but what would
happen you're going to have
1 minus 2 on the denominator negative
yeah
and you're going to have 1 minus 2 to
the power of some stuff this is also
going to be
negative so you just have a double
negative and it's going to cancel out
wouldn't it be better if we just had
something which didn't have the
negatives to begin with
so two minus one gives you one really
easy okay
now there's a sneaky thing i'm going to
give you another example down here right
there's a sneaky thing
that gps do i wonder if you remember
that aps
cannot do which is that if you had a
sequence like say this
here is another gp
okay common ratio here is not it's not
doubling it's halving this term
right what's interesting about this guy
is if you went
forever right there's this sort of um
number that you can never get bigger
than like no matter you could have a
hundred terms or a thousand terms or a
million terms
and you can never get past that number
you can never get bigger than that
right does anyone remember what that's
called starts with an l
there's a there's a limit to the size of
this right so we call it
not just a sum but a limiting
sum and we don't write it with an n
because we're kind of like this is just
don't worry about 100 or a thousand
terms what if you took all the terms
okay now this is going to be based on
what's a good color to use it's going to
be based on this guy
up here it looks very very similar does
anyone remember how we take this guy
and turn it into the limiting sum you
don't have to think
it's still a fraction
if you've got a a ratio that's small
like i say a half
right what happens to this guy up here
have a look
in the numerator what happens to this
guy here if you
get really really big values of n right
if you have half
and then you multiply it by itself like
a hundred times or a thousand times
it gets really small right it goes
smaller and smaller like these numbers
get smaller
right so this guy right here that r to
the unit approaches zero
so if this approaches zero what is one
minus that approach
what just approaches one so you just get
left with that a
on the top a times one which is going to
give you a and then everything else is
the same so this guy here is what we
call the limiting sum
you only get it when your ratio is
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
so the way we would say it is if you're
um sorry not your ratio if your
successive terms are getting smaller and
smaller and smaller
so the way we'd say that is if your
ratio is between
negative one and one okay now so
yeah oh you are you talking about
this guy here yeah you could write it as
an absolute value i actually i was
like are you asking why do they have an
absolute value i was deliberately
avoiding that
um because we don't need to worry about
that language there because um
this is saying the same thing as this
if i take the absolute value i don't
care whether it's negative or positive
so long as it's
small enough if that makes sense so um a
common ratio of negative a half would
have worked just fine as well
now i know that's a lot to take in but
that was a whole topic like that's
that's the whole topic okay so to get us
back in the frame of mind before we
really dig into
all that finance stuff um we're gonna
have a look at
this exercise which will get us back
into like what's an ap again
what's a gp just to get the gears
turning again and then we'll really dive
deep
into all these special financial ideas